PROFESSOR: Hi, everyone.
We're getting started now.
So this week's lecture
is really picking up
where last week's left off.
You may remember we spent
the last week talking
about cause inference.
And I told you
how, for last week,
we're going to focus
on a one-time setting.
Well, as we know,
lots of medicine
has to do with multiple
sequential decisions
across time.
And that'll be the focus
of this whole week's
worth of discussions.
And as I thought about
really what should I
teach in this
lecture, I realized
that the person who knew
the most about the topic
was in fact a postdoctoral
researcher in my lab.
Most about this topic
in the general area
of the medical field.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: Thanks.
I'll take it.
AUDIENCE: Global [INAUDIBLE].
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON:
It's very fair.
PROFESSOR: And so I invited
him to come to us today
and to give this as
an invited lecture.
And this is Fredrik Johansson.
He'll be a professor in
Chalmers, in Sweden, starting
in September.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON:
Thank you so much, David.
That's very generous.
Yeah, so as David
mentioned, last time we
looked a lot at causal effects.
And that's where we will
start on this discussion, too.
So I'll just start
with this reminder,
here-- we essentially introduced
four quantities last time,
or the last two lectures,
as far as I know.
We had two potential outcomes,
which represented the outcomes
that we would see of
some treatment choice
under the various choices.
So, the two different choices--
1 and 0.
We had a set of covariates,
x and a treatment, t.
And we were interested
in, essentially,
what is the effect
of this treatment, t,
on the outcome, y,
given the covariates, x.
And the effect that we
focused on that time
was the conditional
average treatment effect,
which is exactly the
difference between
these potential outcomes--
a condition on the features.
So the whole last
week was about trying
to identify this quantity
using various methods.
And the question that
didn't come up so much--
or one question that
didn't come up too much--
is how do we use this quantity?
We might be
interested in it, just
in terms of its
absolute magnitude.
How large is the effect?
But we might also be
interested in designing
a policy for how to
treat our patients based
on this quantity.
So today, we will
focus on policies.
And what I mean by
that, specifically,
is something that
takes into account
what we know about a patient and
produces a choice or an action
as an output.
Typically, we'll
think of policies
as depending on medical
history, perhaps
which treatments they
have received previously,
what state is the
patient currently in.
But we can also base it
purely on this number
that we produce last time-- the
conditional average treatment
effect.
And one very natural
policy is to say, pi of x
is equal to the
indicator function
representing if this
CATE is positive.
So if the effect is positive,
we treat the patient.
If the effect is
negative, we don't.
And of course, positive will
be relative to the usefulness
of the outcome being high.
But yeah, this is a very
natural policy to consider.
However, we can also think about
much more complicated policies
that are not just
based on this number--
the quality of the outcome.
We can think about
policies that take
into account legislation or cost
of medication or side effects.
We're not going
to do that today,
but that's something
that you can keep in mind
as we discuss these things.
So David mentioned,
we should now
move from the one-step
setting, where
we have a single treatment
acting at a single time
and we only have to take
into account the state
of a patient once, basically.
And we will move from that
to the sequential setting.
And my first example of such a
setting is sepsis management.
So, sepsis is a complication
of an infection, which can have
very disastrous consequences.
It can lead to organ failure
and ultimately death.
And it's actually
one of the leading
causes of deaths in the ICU.
So it's of course important
that we can manage and treat
this condition.
When you start treating
sepsis, the primary target--
the first things you
should think about fixing--
is the infection itself.
If we don't treat
the infection, things
are going to keep being bad.
But even if we figure
out the right antibiotic
to treat the infection that is
the source of the septic shock
or the septic
inflammation, there
are a lot of
different conditions
that we need to manage.
Because the infection
itself can lead to fever,
breathing difficulties, low
blood pressure, high heart
rate--
all these kinds of things
that are symptoms, but not
the cause in themselves.
But we still have to
manage them somehow
so that the patient
survives and is comfortable.
So when I say sepsis
management, I'm
talking about managing
such quantities over time--
over a patient's
stay in the hospital.
So, last time-- again, just
to really hammer this in-- we
talked about potential
outcomes and the choice
of a single treatment.
So we can think about this in
the septic setting as a patient
coming in-- or a patient
already being in the hospital,
presumably--
and is presenting with
breathing difficulties.
So that means that their blood
oxygen will be low because they
can't breathe on their own.
And we might want to put them
on mechanical ventilation
so that we can ensure that
they get sufficient oxygen.
We can view this
as a single choice.
Should we put the patient on
mechanical ventilation or not?
But what we need to
take into account here
is what will happen after
we make that choice.
What will be the side effects
of this choice going further?
Because we want to make sure
that the patient is comfortable
and in good health
throughout their stay.
So today, we will move towards
sequential decision making.
And in particular, what
I alluded to just now
is that decisions
made in sequence
may have the property that
choices early on rule out
certain choices later.
And we'll see an example
of that very soon.
And in particular, we'll
be interested in coming up
with a policy for making
decisions repeatedly
that optimizes a given outcome--
something that we care about.
It could be minimize
the risk of death.
It could be a reward that says
that the vitals of a patients
are in the right range.
We might want to optimize that.
But essentially,
think about it now as
having this choice
of administering
a medication or an
intervention at any time, t--
and having the best
policy for doing so.
OK, I'm going to skip that one.
OK, so I mentioned already
one potential choice
that we might want to
make in the management
of a septic patient,
which is to put them
on mechanical ventilation
because they can't breathe
on their own.
A side effect of
doing so is that they
might suffer discomfort
from being intubated.
The procedure is not painless,
it's not without discomfort.
So something that you
might have to do--
putting them on
mechanical ventilation--
is to sedate the patient.
So this is an action
that is informed
by the previous action,
because if we didn't
put the patient on
mechanical ventilation,
maybe we wouldn't consider
them for sedation.
When we sedate a
patient, we run the risk
of lowering their
blood pressure.
So we might need to
manage that, too.
So if their blood
pressure gets too low,
maybe we need to
administer vasopressors,
which artificially raise
the blood pressure,
or fluids or anything else
that takes care of this issue.
So just think of
this as an example
of choices cascading, in
terms of their consequences,
as we roll forward in time.
Ultimately, we will face the
end of the patient's stay.
And hopefully, we managed the
patient in a successful way
so that their response or
their outcome is a good one.
What I'm illustrating
here is that, for any one
patient in our hospitals or
in the health care system,
we will only observe
one trajectory
through these options.
So I will show this type
of illustration many times,
but I hope that you can realize
the scope of the decision space
here.
Essentially, at any point, we
can choose a different action.
And usually, the
number of decisions
that we make in an ICU
setting, for example,
is much larger
than we could ever
test in a randomized trial.
Think of all of these
different trajectories
as being different arms in a
randomized controlled trial
that you want to compare the
effects or the outcomes of.
It's infeasible to run
such a trial, typically.
So one of the big
reasons that we
are talking about reinforcement
learning today and talking
about learning
policies, rather than
causal effects in the setup
that we did last week,
is because the space of
possible action trajectories
is so large.
Having said that, we now
turn to trying to find,
essentially, the policy that
picks this orange path here--
that leads to a good outcome.
And to reason
about such a thing,
we need to also reason about
what is a good outcome?
What is good reward for
our agent, as it proceeds
through time and makes choices?
Some policies that we
produce as machine learners
might not be appropriate
for a health care setting.
We have to somehow restrict
ourself to something that's
realistic.
I won't focus very
much on this today.
It's something that will come
up in the discussion tomorrow,
hopefully.
And also the notion of
evaluating something
for use in the
health care system
will also be talked
about tomorrow.
AUDIENCE: Thursday.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON:
Sorry, Thursday.
Next time.
OK, so I'll start by just
briefly mentioning some success
stories.
And these are not
from the health care
setting, as you can
guess from the pictures.
How many have seen
some of these pictures?
OK, great-- almost everyone.
Yeah, so these are from various
video games-- almost all
of them.
Well, games anyhow.
And these are good examples
of when reinforcement learning
works, essentially.
That's why I use these
in this slide here--
because, essentially,
it's very hard
to argue that the
computer or the program
that eventually beat Lee Sedol.
I think it's in this picture
but also, later, Go champions,
essentially.
In the AlphaGo picture
in the top left,
it's hard to argue that
they're not doing a good job,
because they clearly
beat humans here.
But one of the things
I want you to keep
in mind throughout
this talk is what
is different between
these kinds of scenarios?
And we'll come
back to that later.
And what is different
to the health
care setting, essentially?
So I simply added
another example here,
that's why I recognize it.
So there was recently one
that's a little bit closer
to my heart, which is AlphaStar.
I play StarCraft.
I like StarCraft, so it
should be on the slide.
Anyway, let's move on.
Broadly speaking,
these can be summarized
in the following picture.
What goes into those systems?
There's a lot more nuance when
it comes to something like Go.
But for the purpose
of this class,
we will summarize
them with a slide.
So essentially, one of
the three quantities
that matters for a
reinforcement learning
is the state of the environment,
the state of the game,
the state of the patient--
the state of the thing that we
want to optimize, essentially.
So in this case, I've
chosen Tic-tac-toe here.
We have a state which
represents the current positions
of the circles and crosses.
And given that state of the
game, my job as a player
is to choose one of
the possible actions--
one of the free squares
to put my cross in.
So I'm the blue
player here and I
can consider these five choices
for where to put my next cross.
And each of those will lead
me to a new state of the game.
If I put my cross
over here, that
means that I'm now in this box.
And I have a new set of
actions available to me
for the next round, depending
on what the red player does.
So we have the state,
we have the actions,
and we have the next
state, essentially--
we have a trajectory or
a transition of states.
And the last quantity that we
need is the notion of a reward.
That's very important
for reinforcement
learning, because that's what's
driving the learning itself.
We strive to optimize the reward
or the outcome of something.
So if we look at the action
to the farthest right here,
essentially I left myself open
to an attack by the red player
here, because I didn't
put my cross there.
Which means that, probably,
if the red player is decent,
he will put his
circle here and I
will incur a loss, essentially.
So my reward will be negative,
if we take positive to be good.
And this is something that I
can learn from going forward.
Essentially, what
I want to avoid
is ending up in
this state that's
shown in the bottom right here.
This is the basic
idea of reinforcement
learning for video games
and for anything else.
So if we take this board
analogy or this example
and move to the
health care setting,
we can think of the state of
a patient as the game board
or the state of the game.
We will always call
this St in this talk.
The treatments that we prescribe
or interventions will be At.
And these are like the actions
in the game, obviously.
The outcomes of a patient--
could be mortality,
could be managing vitals--
will be as the rewards in
the game, having lost or won.
And then up at the end here,
what could possibly go wrong.
Well, as I alluded
to before, health
is not a game in the same sense
that a video game is a game.
But they share a lot of
mathematical structure.
So that's why I make
the analogy here.
These quantities
here-- S, A, and R--
will form something
called a decision process.
And that's what we'll
talk about next.
This is the outline
for today and Thursday.
I won't get to this
today, but this
is the talks we're considering.
So a decision process
is essentially
the world that describes
the data that we access
or the world that we're
managing our agent in.
Very often, if you've ever seen
reinforcement learning taught,
you have seen this picture
in some form, usually.
Sometimes there's a
mouse and some cheese
and there's other
things going on,
but you know what
I'm talking about.
But there are the
same basic components.
So there's the
concept of an agent--
let's think doctor for now--
that takes actions
repeatedly over time.
So this t here indicates
an index of time
and we see that
essentially increasing
as we spin around
this wheel here.
We move forward in time.
So an agent takes an action
and, at any time point,
receives a reward
for that action.
And that would be
Rt, as I said before.
The environment is responsible
for giving that reward.
So for example, if I'm
the doctor, I'm the agent,
I make an action or an
intervention to my patient,
the patient will
be the environment.
And essentially, responses do
not respond to my intervention.
The state here is the
state of the patient,
as I mentioned
before, for example.
But it might also be a state
more broadly than the patient,
like the settings of the
machine that they're attached to
or the availability of
certain drugs in the hospital
or something like that.
So we can think
a little bit more
broadly around the patient, too.
I said partially observed here,
in that I might not actually
know everything about the
patient that's relevant to me.
And we will come back a
little bit later to that.
So there are two different
formalizations that are very
close to each other, which
is when you'd know everything
about s and when you don't.
We will, for the longest
part of this talk,
focus on the way I
know everything that is
relevant about the environment.
OK, to make this all
a bit more concrete,
I'll return to the picture
that I showed you before,
but now put it in context
of the paper that you read.
Was that the compulsory one?
The mechanical ventilation?
OK, great.
So in this case, they had an
interesting reward structure,
essentially.
The thing that they
were trying to optimize
was the reward related to
the vitals of the patient.
But also whether they were
kept on mechanical ventilation
or not.
And the idea of this
paper is that you
don't want to keep a
patient unnecessarily
on mechanical ventilation,
because it has the side effects
that we talked about before.
So at any point in
time, essentially,
we can think about taking
a patient on or off--
and also dealing with
the sedatives that
are prescribed to them.
So in this example, the
state that they considered
in this application included
the demographic information
of the patient, which doesn't
really change over time.
Their physiological
measurements,
ventilator settings,
consciousness level,
the dosages of the
sedatives they use,
which could be an
action, I suppose--
and a number of other things.
And these are the values that
we have to keep track of,
moving forward in time.
The actions concretely included
whether to intubate or extubate
the patient, as well
as the administer
and dosing the sedatives.
So this is, again, an example
of a so-called decision process.
And essentially, the
process is the distribution
of these quantities that I've
been talking about over time.
So we have the states, the
actions, and the rewards.
They all traverse or they
all evolve over time.
And the loss of how that
happens is the decision process.
I mentioned before
that we will be
talking about policies today.
And typically,
there's a distinction
between what is called a
behavior policy and a target
policy-- or there are
different words for this.
Essentially, the
thing that we observe
is usually called
a behavior policy.
By that, I mean if we go to
a hospital and watch what's
happening there at
the moment, that
will be the behavior policy.
And I will denote that mu.
So that is what we have to
learn from, essentially.
So decision processes so
far are incredibly general.
I haven't said anything about
what this distribution is like,
but the absolutely
dominant restriction
that people make when they
study system processes
is to look at Markov
decision processes.
And these have a specific
conditional independent
structure that I will illustrate
in the next slide-- well,
I'll just define it
mathematically here.
It says, essentially,
that all of the quantities
that we care about-- the states.
I guess that should say state.
Rewards and the actions only
depend on the most recent state
in action.
If we observe an action taken
by a doctor in the hospital,
for example--
to make a mark of
assumption, we'd
say that this
doctor did not look
at anything that
happened earlier
in time or any other
information than what
is in the state variable
that we observe at that time.
That is the assumption
that we make.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is that an assumption
you can make for a health care?
Because in the end, you don't
have access to the real state,
but only about what's measured
about the state in health care.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON:
It's a very good question.
So the nice thing in terms of
inferring causal quantities
is that we only
need the things that
were used to make the
decision in the first place.
So the doctor can only act
on such information, too.
Unless we don't
record everything
that the doctor knows--
which is also the case.
So that is something that we
have to worry about for sure.
Another way to lose
information, as I mentioned,
that is relevant for
this is if we look to--
What's the opposite of far?
AUDIENCE: Near.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: Too near
back in time, essentially.
So we don't look at the
entire history of the patient.
And when I say St
here, it doesn't
have to be the instantaneous
snapshot of a patient.
We can also Include
history there.
Again, we'll come back
to that a little later.
OK, so the Markov assumption
essentially looks like this.
Or this is how I will
illustrate, anyway.
We have a sequence of states
here that evolve over time.
I'm allowing myself
to put some dots here,
because I don't want
to draw forever.
But essentially, you could think
of this pattern repeating--
where the previous state
goes into the next state,
the action goes
into the next state,
and the action and state
goes in through the reward.
This is the world that we
will live in for this lecture.
Something that's not allowed
under the mark of assumption
is an edge like this, which says
that an action at an early time
influences an action
at a later time.
And specifically, it can't
do so without passing
through a state, for example.
It very well can
have an influence
on At by this trajectory
here, but not directly.
That that's the Markov
assumption in this case.
So you can see that if I
were to draw the graph of all
the different
measurements that we
see during a state,
essentially there
are a lot of errors that I could
have had in this picture that I
don't have.
So it may seem that the
Markov assumption is
a very strong one, but one
way to ensure that the Markov
assumption is more likely
is to include more things
in your state, including
summaries of the history,
et cetera, that I
mentioned before.
An even stronger restriction
of decision processes
is to assume that
the states over time
are themselves independent.
So this goes by
different names--
sometimes under the
name contextual bandits.
But the bandits part of that
itself is not so relevant here.
So let's not go into
that name too much.
But essentially, what
we can say is here,
the state at a later time point
is not influenced directly
by the state at a
previous time point,
nor the action of the
previous time point.
So if you remember
what you did last week,
this looks like
basically T repetitions
of the very simple
graph that we had
for estimating
potential outcomes.
And that is indeed
mathematically equivalent.
If we assume that
this S here represents
the state of a patient
and all patients
are drawn from some sum
process, essentially.
So that S0, 1, et cetera,
up to St are all i.i.d.
draws of the same distribution.
Then we have,
essentially, a model
for t different patients
with a single time step
or single action,
instead of them
being dependent in some way.
So we can see that by going
backwards through my slides,
this is essentially
what we had last week.
And we just have
to add more arrows
to get to whatever we have
this week, which indicates
that last week was a
special case of this--
just as David said before.
It also hints at the
reinforcement learning problem
being more complicated than
the potential outcomes problem.
And we'll see more
examples of that later.
But, like with causal
effect estimation
that we did last week, we're
interested in the influences
of just a few
variables, essentially.
So last time we studied the
effect of a single treatment
choice.
And in this case, we
will study the influence
of these various actions
that we take along the way.
That will be the goal.
And it could be either
through an immediate effect
on the immediate reward or
it can be through the impact
that an action has on the
state trajectory itself.
I told you about the
world now that we live in.
We have these Ss and As and Rs.
And I haven't told you so
much about the goal that we're
trying to solve or the problem
that we're trying to solve.
Most RL-- or reinforcement
and learning--
is aimed at optimizing
the value of a policy
or finding a policy
that has a good return,
a good sum of rewards.
There are many names for
this, but essentially a policy
that does well.
The notion of well that we
will be using in this lecture
is that of a return.
So the return at a time step
t, following the policy, pi,
that I had before, is the
sum of the future rewards
that we see if we were to
act according to that policy.
So essentially, I stop now.
I ask, OK, if I keep on
doing the same as I've
done through my whole life--
maybe that was a good policy.
I don't know.
And keep going until the end
of time, how well will I do?
What is the sum of those
rewards that I get, essentially?
That's the return.
The value is the
expectation of such things.
So if I'm not the
only person, but there
is the whole population
of us, the expectation
over that population is
the value of the policy.
So if we take patients as a
better analogy than my life,
maybe, the expectation
is over patients.
If we fact on every patient in
our population the same way--
according to the same
policy, that is--
what is the expected
return over those patients?
So as an example, I drew
a few trajectories again,
because I like drawing.
And we can think about three
different patients here.
They start in different states.
And they will have different
action trajectories
as a result.
So we're treating them
with the same policy.
Let's call it pi.
But because they're
in different states,
they will have different
actions at the same times.
So here we take a 0
action, we go down.
Here, we take a 0
That's what that means here.
The specifics of this
is not so important.
But what I want you
to pay attention to
is that, after each
action, we get a reward.
And at the end, we can sum
those up and that's our return.
So each patient has one value
for their own trajectory.
And the value of the policy
is then the average value
of such trajectories.
So that is what we're
trying to optimize.
We have now a notion of good
and we want to find a pi such
that V pi up there is good.
That's the goal.
So I think it's time for
a bit of an example here.
I want you to play
along in a second.
You're going to
solve this problem.
It's not a hard one.
So I think you'll manage.
I think you'll be fine.
But this is now yet another
example of a world to be in.
This is the robot in a room.
And I've stolen this
slide from David,
who stole it from Peter Bodik.
Yeah, so credits to him.
The rules of this world
says the following--
if you tell the robot, who is
traversing this set of tiles
here--
if you tell the robot
to go up, there's
a chance he doesn't go up,
but goes somewhere else.
So we have the stochastic
transitions, essentially.
If I say up, he
goes up with point
a probability and somewhere else
with uniform probability, say.
So 0.8 up and then 0.2--
this is the only
possible direction
to go in if you start here.
So 0.2 in that way.
There's a chance you move in
the wrong direction is what
I'm trying to illustrate here.
There's no chance
that they're going
in the opposite direction.
So if I say right here,
it can't go that way.
The rewards in
this game is plus 1
in the green box up there,
minus 1 in the box here.
And these are also
terminal states.
So I haven't told
you what that is,
but it's essentially a state
in which the game ends.
So once you get to either plus
1 or minus 1, the game is over.
For each step that
the robot takes,
it incurs 0.04 negative reward.
So that says,
essentially, that if you
keep going for a long time,
your reward would be bad.
The value of the
policy will be bad.
So you want to be efficient.
So basically, you
can figure out--
you want to get to the green
thing, that's one part of it.
But you also want
to do it quickly.
So what I want you to do now
is to essentially figure out
what is the best
policy, in terms
of in which way should
the arrows point in each
of these different boxes?
Fill in the question
mark with an arrow
pointing in some direction.
We know the different
transitions will be stochastic,
so you might need to
take that into account.
But essentially,
figure out how do
I have a policy that gives me
the biggest expected reward?
And I'll ask you in a
few minutes if one of you
is brave enough to put it on the
board or something like that.
AUDIENCE: We start the
discount over time?
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON:
There's no discount.
AUDIENCE: Can we
talk to our neighbor?
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: Yes.
It's encouraged.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON:
So I had a question.
What is the action space?
And essentially, the action
space is always up, down,
left, or right, depending
on if there's a wall or not.
So you can't go right
here, for example.
AUDIENCE: You can't
go left either.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: You
can't go left, exactly.
Good point.
So each box at the
end, when you're done,
should contain an arrow
pointing in some direction.
All right, I think
we'll see if anybody
has solved this problem now.
Who thinks they have solved it?
Great.
Would you like to
share your solution?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I think
it's going to go up first.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: I'm going
to try and replicate this.
Ooh, sorry about that.
OK, you're saying up here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The basic idea is you want to
reduce the chance that you're
ever adjacent to the red box.
So just do everything you
can to stay far from it.
Yeah, so attempt
to go up and then
once you eventually get there,
you just have to go right.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: OK.
And then?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: OK.
So what about these ones?
This is also part of
the policy, by the way.
AUDIENCE: I hadn't
thought about this.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: OK.
AUDIENCE: But those,
you [INAUDIBLE],, right?
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: No.
AUDIENCE: Minus 0.04.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON:
So discount
usually means something else.
We'll get to that later.
But that is a reward for
just taking any step.
If you move into a space
that is not terminal,
you incur that negative reward.
AUDIENCE: So if you
keep bouncing around
for a really long time, you
incur a long negative reward.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON:
If we had this,
there's some chance I'd
never get out of all this.
And very little chance
of that working out.
But it's a very bad
policy, because you
keep moving back and forth.
All right, we had
an arm somewhere.
What should I do here?
AUDIENCE: You could take a vote.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: OK.
Who thinks right?
Really?
Who thinks left?
OK, interesting.
I don't actually remember.
Let's see.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I was just
saying, that's an easy one.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON:
Yeah, so this is the part
that we already determined.
If we had deterministic
transitions,
this would be great,
because we don't have
to think about the other ones.
This is what Peter
put on the slide.
So I'm going to have to disagree
with the vote there, actually.
It depends, actually,
heavily on the minus 0.04.
So if you increase
that by a little bit,
you might want to
go that way instead.
Or if you decrease--
I don't remember.
Decrease, exactly.
And if you increase it, you
might get something else.
It might actually be
good to terminate.
So those details
matter a little bit.
But I think you've
got the general idea.
And especially I like
that you commented
that you want to stay
away from the red one,
because if you look at
these different paths.
You go up there and there--
they have the same
number of states,
but there's less chance
you end up in the red box
if you take the upper route.
Great.
So we have an
example of a policy
and we have an example
of a decision process.
And things are
working out so far.
But how do we do this?
As far as the class goes, this
was a blackbox experiment.
I don't know anything about
how you figured that out.
So reinforcement
learning is about that--
reinforcement learning
is try and come
up with a policy in a rigorous
way, hopefully-- ideally.
So that would be
the next topic here.
Up until this point, are there
any questions that you've been
dying to ask, but haven't?
AUDIENCE: I'm curious how
much behavioral biases could
play into the first
Markov assumption?
So for example, if
you're a clinician who's
been working for
30 years and you're
just really used to giving
a certain treatment.
An action that you
gave in the past--
that habit might influence
an action in the future.
And if that is a
worry, how one might
think about addressing it.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON:
Interesting.
I guess it depends a little
bit on how it manifests,
in that if it also influenced
your most recent action, maybe
you have an observation of
that already in some sense.
It's a very broad question.
What effect will that have?
Did you have something
specific in mind?
AUDIENCE: I guess I
was just wondering
if it violated that assumption,
that an action of the past
influenced an action--
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON:
Interesting.
So I guess my response there is
that the action didn't really
depend on the choice
of action before,
because the policy
remained the same.
You could have a bias towards
an action without that
being dependent on what
you gave as action before,
if you know what I mean.
Say my probability of
giving action one is 1,
then it doesn't matter
that I give it in the past.
My policy is still the same.
So, not necessarily.
It could have
other consequences.
We might have reason to come
back to that question later.
Yup.
AUDIENCE: Just
practically, I would
think that a doctor would
want to be consistent.
And so you wouldn't,
for example,
want to put somebody
on a ventilator
and then immediately take them
off and then immediately put
them back on again.
So that would be
an example where
the past action influences
what you're going to do.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON:
Completely, yeah.
I think that's a great example.
And what you would hope is that
the state variable in that case
includes some notion
of treatment history.
That's what your job is then.
So that's why state can
be somewhat misleading
as a term-- at least
for me, I'm not
American or English-speaking.
But yeah, I think of it as
too instantaneous sometimes.
So we'll move into
reinforcement learning now.
And what I had you do
on the last slide--
well, I don't know which
method you use, but most likely
the middle one.
There are three very
common paradigms
for reinforcement learning.
And they are essentially divided
by what they focus on modeling.
Unsurprisingly,
model-based RL focused on--
well, it has some sort
of model in it, at least.
What you mean by
model in this case
is a model of the transitions.
So what state will I end up in,
given the action in the state
I'm in at the moment?
So model-based RL tries to
essentially create a model
for the environment
or of the environment.
There are several examples
of model-based RL.
One of them is
G-computation, which
comes out of the statistic
literature, if you like.
And MDPs are essentially--
that's a Markov
decision process,
which is essentially trying to
estimate the whole distribution
that we talked about before.
There are various ups
and downsides of this.
We won't have time to go into
all of these paradigms today.
We will actually focus only
on value-based RL today.
Yeah, you can ask me
offline if you are
interested in model-based RL.
The rightmost one here
is policy-based RL,
where you essentially
focus only on modeling
the policy that was used in
the data that you observed.
And the policy that you want
to essentially arrive at.
So you're optimizing
a policy and you
are estimating a policy
that was used in the past.
And the middle one focuses
on neither of those
and focuses on only
estimating the return--
that was the G. Or the
reward function as a function
of your actions and states.
And it's interesting
to me that you
can pick any of the variables--
A, S, and R-- and model those.
And you can arrive at something
reasonable in reinforcement
learning.
This one is particularly
interesting,
because it doesn't
try to understand
how do you arrive at
a certain return based
on the actions in the states?
It's just optimize
the policy directly.
And it has some obvious--
well, not obvious, but it has
some downsides, not doing that.
OK, anyway, we're going to
focus on value-based RL.
And the very dominant
instantiation of value-based RL
is Q-learning.
I'm sure you've heard of it.
It is what drove the success
stories that I showed before,
the goal in the
StarCraft and everything.
G-estimation is another example
of this, which, again, has come
from the statistic literature.
But we'll focus on
Q-learning today.
So Q-learning is an example
of dynamic programming,
in some sense.
That's how it's
usually explained.
And I just wanted to check--
how many have heard the phrase
dynamic programming before?
OK, great.
So I won't go into details of
dynamic programming in general.
But the general idea
is one of recursion.
In this case, you know
something about what
is a good terminal state.
And then you want to
figure out how to get there
and how to get to the state
before that and the state
before that and so on.
That is the recursion
that we're talking about.
The end state that is the
best here is fairly obvious--
that is the plus 1 here.
The only way to get there
is by stopping here first,
because you can't move from here
since it's a terminal state.
Your only bet is that one.
And then we can ask what is
the best way to get to 3, 1?
How do we get to the state
before the best state?
Well, we can say that
one way is go from here.
And one way from here.
And as we got from
the audience before,
this is a slightly worse
way to get there then
from there, because here we
have a possibility of ending up
in minus 1.
So then we recurse
further and essentially,
we end up with something
like this that says--
or what I tried to illustrate
here is that the green boxes--
I'm sorry for any colorblind
members of the audience,
because this was a
poor choice of mine.
Anyway, this bottom
side here is mostly red
and this is mostly green.
And you can follow the green
color here, essentially,
to get to the best end state.
And what I used here
to color this in
is this idea of knowing
how good a state is,
depending on how good the
state after that state is.
So I knew that plus 1 is a
good end state over there.
And that led me to recurse
backwards, essentially.
So the question,
then, is how do we
know that that state
over there is a good one?
When we have it
visualized in front of us,
it's very easy to see.
And it's very easy because we
know that plus 1 is a terminal
state here.
It ends there, so those
are the only states we
need to consider in this case.
But more in general,
how do we learn
what is the value of a state?
That will be the
purpose of Q-learning.
If we have an idea of
what is a good state,
we can always do that recursion
that I explained very briefly.
You find a state that
has the high value
and you figure out
how to get there.
So we're going to have to
define now what I mean by value.
I've used that word a
few different times.
I say recall here, but I
don't know if I actually
had it on a slide before.
So let's just say this is
the definition of value
that we will be working with.
I think I had it on a
slide before, actually.
This is the expected return.
Remember, this G
here was the sum
of rewards going into the
future, starting at time, t.
And the value,
then, of this state
is the expectation
of such returns.
Before, I said that
the value of an policy
was the expectation
of returns, period.
And the value of a
state and the policy
is the value of that return
starting in a certain state.
We can stratify this
further if we like and say
that the value of
a state action pair
is the expected return,
starting in a certain state
and taking an action, a.
And after that,
following the policy, pi.
This would be the
so-called Q value
of a state-action pair-- s, a.
And this is where
Q-learning gets its name.
So Q-learning attempts to
estimate the Q function--
the expected return starting in
a state, s, and taking action,
a--
from data.
The Q-learning is
also associated
with a deterministic policy.
So the policy and the
Q function go together
in this specific way.
If we have a Q
function, Q, that tries
to estimate the value of a
policy, pi, the pi itself is
the arg max according to that
Q. It sounds a little recursive,
but hopefully it will be OK.
Maybe it's more obvious
if we look here.
So Q, I said before, was
the value of starting an s,
taking action, a, and
then following policy, pi.
This is defined by the
decision process itself.
The best pi, the best policy, is
the one that has the highest Q.
And this is what
we call a Q-star.
Well, that is not what
we call Q-star, that
is what we call little q-star.
Q-star, the best estimate of
this, is obviously the thing
itself.
So if you can find
a good function that
assigns a value to
a state-action pair,
the best such
function you can get
is the one that is
equal to little q-star.
I hope that wasn't
too confusing.
I'll show on the next slide
why that might be reasonable.
So Q-learning is based
on a general idea
from dynamic programming,
which is the so-called Bellman
question.
There we go.
This is an instantiation of
Bellman optimality, which
says that the best
state-action value
function has the
property that it
is equal to the immediate reward
of taking action, a, and state,
s, plus this, which
is the maximum Q
value for the next state.
So we're going to stare
at this for a bit,
because there's a
bit here to digest.
Remember, q-star assigns a
value to any state action pair.
So we have q-star here,
we have q-star here.
This thing here is supposed
to represent the value going
forward in time after I've
made this choice, action, a,
and state, s.
If I have a good idea of how
good it is to take action,
a, instead of s, it should
both incorporate the immediate
reward that I get-- that's RT--
and how good that choice
was going forward.
So think about mechanical
ventilation, as I said before.
If we put a patient on
mechanical ventilation,
we have to do a bunch of
other things after that.
If none of those other things
lead to a good outcome,
this part will be low.
Even if the immediate
return is good.
So for the optimal q-star,
this quantity holds.
We know that-- we
can prove that.
So the question is how
do we find this thing?
How do we find q-star?
Because q-star is not only
the thing that gives you
the optimal policy--
it also satisfied this equality.
This is not true for
every Q function,
but it's true for
the optimal one.
Questions?
If you haven't seen this before,
it might be a little tough
to digest.
Is the notation clear?
Essentially, here
you have the state
that you are arriving
at the next time.
A prime is the parameter of this
here, or the argument to this.
You're taking the best
possible q-star value and then
state that you arrive at after.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Can you instantiate an
example you have on the board?
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: Yes.
Actually, I might do a
full example of Q-learning
in a second.
Yes, I will.
I'll get to that example then.
Yeah, I was debating
whether to do that.
It might take some time,
but it could be useful.
So where are we?
So what I showed you before--
the Bellman inequality.
We know that this holds
for the optimal thing.
And if there is a quality
that is true at an optimum,
one general idea in optimization
is this so-called fixed point
iteration that you can
do to arrive there.
And that's essentially what
we will do to get to a good Q.
So a nice thing
about Q-learning is
that if your states and action
spaces are small and discrete,
you can represent the
Q function as a table.
So all you have to
keep track of is,
how good is the certain
action in a certain state?
Or all actions in
all states, rather?
So that's what we did here.
This is a table.
I've described to you the policy
here, but what we'll do next
is to describe the
value of each action.
So you can think of a value of
taking the right one, bottom,
top, and left, essentially.
Those will be the values
that we need to consider.
And so what Q-learning can
do with discrete states is
to essentially start
from somewhere,
start from some idea of
what Q is-- could be random,
could be 0.
And then repeat the following
fixed-point iteration,
where you update your
former idea of what
Q should be, with
its current value
plus essentially a mixture of
the immediate reward for taking
action, At, in that state,
and the future reward,
as judged by your current
estimate of the Q function.
So we'll do that
now in practice.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Throughout
this, where are we
getting the transition
probabilities
or the behavior of the game?
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: So
they're not used here, actually.
A value-based RL-- I
didn't say that explicitly,
but they don't rely on knowing
the transition probabilities.
What you might ask is where
do we get the S and the As
and the Rs from?
And we'll get to that.
How do we estimate these?
We'll get to that later.
Good question, though.
I'm going to throw a
very messy slide at you.
Here you go.
A lot of numbers.
So what I've done now here
is a more exhaustive version
of what I put on the board.
For each little triangle
here represents the Q value
for the state-action pair.
So this triangle is,
again, for the action right
if you're in this state.
So what I've put on
the first slide here
is the immediate
reward of each action.
So we know that any step
will cost us minus 0.04.
So that's why there's
a lot of those here.
These white boxes here
are not possible actions.
Up here, you have a
0.96, because it's
1, which is the immediate
reward of going right here,
minus 0.04.
These two are minus 1.04
for the same reason--
because you arrive in minus 1.
OK, so that's the first step
and the second step done.
We initialize Qs to be 0.
And then we picked these two
parameters of the problem,
alpha and gamma, to be 1.
And then we did the first
iteration of Q-learning,
where we set the Q to
be the old version of Q,
which was 0, plus alpha
times this thing here.
So Q was 0, that means
that this is also 0.
So the only thing we need to
look at is this thing here.
This also is 0, because
the Qs for all states
were 0, so the only thing
we end up with is R.
And that's what populated
this table here.
Next timestep-- I'm
doing Q-learning now
in a way where I update all
the state-action pairs at once.
How can I do that?
Well, it depends on the question
I got there, essentially.
What data do I observe?
Or how do I get to know the
rewards of the S&A pairs?
We'll come back to that.
So in the next step, I have
to update everything again.
So it's the previous Q
value, which was minus 0.04
for a lot of things, then plus
the immediate reward, which
was this RT.
And I have to keep going.
So the dominant thing
for the table this time
was that the best Q value
for almost all of these boxes
was minus 0.04.
So essentially I will
add the immediate reward
plus that almost everywhere.
What is interesting, though,
is that here, the best Q value
was 0.96.
And it will remain so.
That means that the best Q
value for the adjacent states--
we look at this max
here and get 0.96 out.
And then add the
immediate reward.
Getting to here gives
me 0.96 minus 0.04
for the immediate reward.
And now we can figure out
what will happen next.
These values will spread
out as you go further away
from the plus 1.
I don't think we should
go through all of this,
but you get a
sense, essentially,
how information is moved
from the plus 1 and away.
And I'm sure that's
how you solved
it yourself, in your head.
But this makes it clear
why you can do that,
even if you don't know where
the terminal states are
or where the value of the
state-action pairs are.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't
this calculation
assume that if you want to
move in a certain direction,
you will move in that direction?
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: Yes.
Sorry.
Thanks for reminding me.
That should have been
in the slide, yes.
Thank you.
I'm going to skip
the rest of this.
I hope you forgive me.
We can talk more about it later.
Thanks for reminding
me, Pete, there,
that one of the things
I exploited here
was that I assume just
deterministic transitions.
Another thing that I
relied very heavily on here
is that I can represent
this Q function as a table.
I drew all these boxes and
I filled the numbers in.
That's easy enough.
But what if I have thousands
of states and thousands
of actions?
That's a large table.
And not only is it a large
table for me to keep in memory--
it's also very bad
for me statistically.
If I want to observe anything
about a state-action pair,
I have to do that
action in that state.
And if you think about treating
patients in a hospital,
you're not going to try
everything in every state,
usually.
You're also not going to have
infinite numbers of patients.
So how do you figure out
what is the immediate reward
of taking a certain
action in a certain state?
And this is where a function
approximation comes in.
Essentially, if you can't
represent your data set table,
either for statistical
reasons or for memory reasons,
let's say, you might want to
approximate the Q function
with a parametric or with
a non-parametric function.
And this is exactly
what we can do.
So we can draw now an analogy
to what we did last week.
I'm going to come back
to this, but essentially
instead of doing this
fixed-point iteration that we
did before, we will try and
look for a function Q theta that
is equal to R plus gamma max Q.
Remember before, we had
the Bellman inequality?
We said that q-star S,
A is equal to R S, A,
let's say, plus gamma max A
prime q star S prime A prime,
where S prime is the state
we get to after taking action
A in state S. So the
only thing I've done here
is to take this equality and
make it instead a loss function
on the violation
of this equality.
So by minimizing
this quantity, I
will find something
that has approximately
the Bellman equality that
we talked about before.
This is the idea of
fitted Q-learning, where
you substitute the
tabular representation
with the function
approximations, essentially.
So just to make this
a bit more concrete,
we can think about
the case where
we have only a single step.
There's only a single
action to make,
which means that there is no
future part of this equation
here.
This part goes away,
because there's only one
stage in our trajectory.
So we have only the
immediate reward.
We have only the Q function.
Now, this is exactly a
regression equation in the way
that you've seen it when
estimating potential outcomes.
RT here represents
the outcome of doing
action A and state
S. And Q here will
be our estimate of this RT.
Again, I've said this before--
if we have a single time
point in our process,
the problem reduces
to estimating
potential outcomes,
just the way we
saw it last time.
We have curves that
correspond outcomes
under different actions.
And we can do
regression adjustment,
trying to find an F such
that this quantity is small
so that we can model each
different potential outcomes.
And that's exactly what happens
with the fitted Q iteration
if you have a single
timestep, too.
So to make it even
more concrete,
we can say that there's some
target value, G hat, which
represents the immediate reward
and the future rewards that is
the target of our regression.
And we're fitting some
function to that value.
So the question
we got before was
how do I know the
transition matrix?
How do I get any information
about this thing?
I say here on the
slide that, OK,
we have some target that's
R plus future Q values.
We have some prediction
and we have an expectation
of our transitions here.
But how do I
evaluate this thing?
The transitions I have to
get from somewhere, right?
And another way to say
that is what are the inputs
and the outputs
of our regression?
Because when we estimate
potential outcomes,
we have a very
clear idea of this.
We know that y, the outcome
itself, is a target.
And the input is
the covariates, x.
But here, we have a moving
target, because this Q hat,
it has to come from
somewhere, too.
This is something that
we estimate as well.
So usually what happens is that
we alternate between updating
this target, Q, and Q theta.
So essentially, we copy Q
theta to become our new Q hat
and we iterate this somehow.
But I still haven't told you how
to evaluate this expectation.
So usually in RL, there are a
few different ways to do this.
And either depending on where
you coming from, essentially,
these are varyingly viable.
So if we look back
at this thing here,
it relies on having
tuples of transitions--
the state, the action,
the next state,
and the reward that I got.
So I have to somehow
observe those.
And I can obtain
them in various ways.
A very common one when
it comes to learning
to play video
games, for example,
is that you do something
called on-policy exploration.
That means that you observe
data from the policy
that you're
currently optimizing.
You just play the game
according to the policies
that you have at the moment.
And the analogy in
health care would
be that you have some idea
of how to treat patients
and you just do that
and see what happens.
That could be
problematic, especially
if you've got that policy--
if you randomly initialized
it or if you got it for some
somewhere very suboptimal.
A different thing that
we're more, perhaps,
comfortable with in health
care, in a restricted setting,
is the idea of a
randomized trial, where,
instead of trying out some
policy that you're currently
learning, you decide
on a population
where it's OK to flip
a coin, essentially,
between different
actions that you have.
The difference between
the sequential setting
and the one-step
setting is that now we
have to randomize a
sequence of actions, which
is a little bit unlike
the clinical trials
that you have seen
before, I think.
The last one, which is
the most studied one
when it comes to
practice, I would say,
is the one that we
talk about this week--
is off-policy evaluation
or learning, in which case
you observe health care
records, for example.
You observe registries.
You observe some data from
the health care system
where patients have
already been treated
and you try to
extract a good policy
based on that information.
So that means that you see
these transitions between state
and action and the next
state and the reward.
You see that based on
what happened in the past
and you have to figure
out a pattern there
that helps you come up with a
good action or a good policy.
So we'll focus on
that one for now.
The last part of this talk
will be about, essentially,
what we have to be
careful with when
we learn with off-policy data.
Any questions up
until this point?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if
[INAUDIBLE] getting there
for the [INAUDIBLE],, are
there any requirements that
has to be met by
[INAUDIBLE],, like how
we had [INAUDIBLE]
and cause inference?
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON:
Yeah, I'll get to that
on the next set of slides.
Thank you.
Any other questions about
the Q-learning part?
A colleague of mine,
Rahul, he said--
or maybe he just paraphrased
it from someone else.
But essentially,
you have to see RL
10 times before you get it,
or something to that effect.
I had the same experience.
So hopefully you have
questions for me after.
AUDIENCE: Human
reinforcement learning.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: Exactly.
But I think what you should
take from the last two sections,
if not how to do
Q-learning in detail,
because I glossed
over a lot of things.
You should take with you the
idea of dynamic programming
and figuring out,
how can I learn
about what's good early on in my
process from what's good late?
And the idea of moving
towards a good state
and not just arriving
there immediately.
And there are many ways
to think about that.
OK, we'll move on to
off-policy learning.
And again, the set-up here is
that we receive trajectories
of patient states, actions,
and rewards from some source.
We don't know what these sources
necessarily-- well, we probably
know what the source is.
But we don't know how these
actions were performed,
i.e., we don't know what the
policy was that generated
these trajectories.
And this is the
same set-up as when
you estimated causal effects
last week, to a large extent.
We say that the actions
are drawn, again,
according to some behavior
policy unknown to us.
But we want to
figure out what is
the value of a new policy, pi.
So when I showed
you very early on--
I wish I had that slide again.
But essentially, a bunch of
patient trajectories and some
return.
Patient trajectories,
some return.
The average of those,
that's called a value.
If we have trajectories
according to a certain policy,
that is the value
of that policy--
the average of these things.
But when we have trajectories
according to one policy
and want to figure out
the value of another one,
that's the same problem as the
covariate adjustment problem
that you had last
week, essentially.
Or the confounding
problem, essentially.
The trajectories
that we draw are
biased according to the
policy of the clinician that
created them.
And we want to figure out the
value of a different policy.
So it's the same
as the confounding
problem from the last time.
And because it is the same as
the confounding from last time,
we know that this is at
least as hard as doing that.
We have confounding-- I already
alluded to variance issues.
And you mentioned overlap
or positivity as well.
And in fact, we need to make
the same assumptions but even
stronger assumptions
for this to be possible.
These are sufficient conditions.
So, under very
certain circumstances,
you don't need them.
I should say, these are
fairly general assumptions
that are still strict--
that's how I should put it.
So last time, we
looked at something
called strong ignorability.
I realized the text is
pretty small in here.
Can you see in the back?
Is that OK?
OK, great.
So strong ignorability said
that the potential outcomes--
Y0 and Y1-- are conditionally
independent of the treatment,
t, given the set of variables,
x, or the variable, x.
And that's saying that
it doesn't matter if we
know what treatment was given.
We can figure out
just based on x
what would happen under
either treatment arm, where
we should treat this patient,
with t equals 0, t equals 1.
We had an idea of--
or an assumption
of-- overlap, which
says that any treatment
could be observed
in any state or any context, x.
That's what that means.
And that is only
to ensure that we
can estimate at least a
conditional average treatment
effect at x.
And if we want to estimate
the average treatment
effect in a population,
we would need
to have that for every
x in that population.
So what happens in
the sequential case
is that we need even
stronger assumptions.
There's some notation I
haven't introduced here
and I apologize for that.
But there's a bar here
over these Ss and As--
I don't know if you can see it.
That usually indicates
in this literature
that you're looking at the
sequence, up to the index here.
So all the states up
until t have observed
and all the actions
up until t minus 1.
So in order for the best
policy to be identifiable--
or the value of a positive
to be identifiable--
we need this strong condition.
So the return of a
policy is independent
of the current action,
given everything that
happened in the past.
This is weaker than
the Markov assumption,
to be clear, because there, we
said that anything that happens
in the future is
conditionally independent,
given the current state.
So this is weaker,
because we now
just need to observe
something in the history.
We need to observe all
confounders in the history,
in this instance.
We don't need to
summarize them in S.
And we'll get back to
this in the next slide.
Positivity is the real
difficult one, though,
because what we're saying
is that at any point
in the trajectory, any action
should be possible in order
for us to estimate the value
of any possible policy.
And we know that that's not
going to be true in practice.
We're not going to consider
every possible action
at every possible point in
the health care setting.
There's just no way.
So what that tells
us is that we can't
estimate the value of
every possible policy.
We can only estimate
the value of policies
that are consistent with
the support that we do have.
If we never see
action 4 at time 3,
there's no way we can learn
about a policy that does that--
that takes action 4 at time 3.
That's what I'm trying to say.
So in some sense,
this is stronger,
just because of how
sequential settings work.
It's more about the application
domain than anything,
I would say.
In the next set of
slides, we'll focus on
sequential randomization
or sequential ignorability,
as it's sometimes called.
And tomorrow, we'll
talk a little bit
about the statistics
involved in or resulting
from the positivity
assumption and things
like importance
weighting, et cetera.
Did I say tomorrow?
I meant Thursday.
So last recap on the
potential outcome story.
This is a slide--
I'm not sure if he
showed this one,
but it's one that we
used in a lot of talks.
And it, again, just serves
to illustrate the idea
of a one-timestep decision.
So we have here, Anna.
A patient comes in.
She has high blood sugar
and some other properties.
And we're debating whether to
give her medication A or B.
And to do that, we
want to figure out
what would be her blood sugar
under these different choices
a few months down the line?
So I'm just using this
here to introduce you
to the patient, Anna.
And we're going to talk
about Anna a little bit more.
So treating Anna once, we can
represent as this causal graph
that you've seen a
lot of times now.
We had some treatment,
A, we had some state, S,
and some outcome, R. We want to
figure out the effect of this A
on the outcome, R.
Ignorability in
this case just says
that the potential outcomes
under each action, A,
is conditionally
independent of A, given S.
And so we know that
ignorability and overlap is
sufficient conditions for
identification of this effect.
But what happens now if
we add another time point?
OK, so in this case, if I
have no extra arrows here--
I just have completely
independent time points--
ignorability
clearly still holds.
There's no links going from
A to R, there's no from S
to R, et cetera.
So ignorability is still fine.
If Anna's health status in the
future depends on the actions
that I take now, here,
then the situation
is a little bit different.
So this is now not in the
completely independent actions
that I make, but
the actions here
influence the state
in the future.
So we've seen this.
This is a Markov decision
process, as you've seen before.
This is very likely in practice.
Also, if Anna, for
example, is diabetic,
as we saw in the example
that I mentioned,
it's likely that
she will remain so.
This previous state will
influence the future state.
These things seem very
reasonable, right?
But now I'm trying to
argue about the sequential
ignorability assumption.
How can we break that?
How can we break
ignorability when it
comes to the sequential, say?
If you have an action here--
so the outcome at a later point
depends on an earlier choice.
That might certainly
be the case,
because we could have a
delayed effect of something.
So if we measure,
say, a lab value which
could be in the
right range or not,
it could very well
depend on medication
we gave a long time ago.
And it's also likely
that the reward
could depend on a state which
is much earlier, depending
on what we include in
that state variable.
We already have an example,
I think, from the audience
on that.
So actually, ignorability should
have a big red cross over it,
because it doesn't hold there.
And it's luckily
on the next slide.
Because there are
even more errors
that we can have, conceivably,
in the medical setting.
The example that
we got from Pete
before was, essentially,
that if we've
tried an action previously, we
might not want to try it again.
Or if we knew that
something worked previously,
we might want to do it again.
So if we had a good
reward here, we
might want to do the
same thing twice.
And this arrow here
says that if we
know that a patient had
a symptom earlier on,
we might want to base
our actions on it later.
We've known that the patient
had an allergic reaction
at some point, for example.
We might not want to use that
medication at a later time.
AUDIENCE: But you can always
put everything in a state.
FREDRIK D. JOHANSSON: Exactly.
So this depends on what
you put in the state.
This is an example
where I should introduce
these arrows to show
that, if I haven't
got that information here, then
I introduce this dependence.
So if I don't have
the information
about allergic reaction or
some symptom before in here,
then I have to do
something else.
So exactly that is the point.
If I can summarize
history in some good way--
if I can compress all
of these four variables
into some variable age
standard for the history,
then I have ignorability,
with respect to that history,
H. This is your solution and
it introduces a new problem,
because history is usually
a really large thing.
We know that history grows
with time, obviously.
But usually we don't
observe patients
for the same number
of time points.
So how do we represent
that for a program?
How do we represent that
to a learning algorithm?
That's something we
have to deal with.
You can pad history
with 0s, et cetera,
but if you keep every
timestep and repeat
every variable in
every timestep,
you get a very large object.
That might introduce
statistical problems,
because now you have
much more variance if you
have new variables, et cetera.
So one thing that
people do is that they
look some amount of
time backwards-- so
instead of just looking
at one timestep back,
you now look at a
length k window.
And your state essentially
grows by a factor, k.
And another alternative
is to try and learn
a summary function.
Learn some function that
is relevant for predicting
the outcome that takes all
of the history into account,
but has a smaller representation
than just t times the variables
that you have.
But this is something that
needs to happen, usually.
Most health care
data, in practice--
you have to make
choices about this.
I just want to stress that
that's something you really
can't avoid.
The last point I want to make
is that unobserved confounding
is also a problem that
is not avoidable just
due to summarizing history.
We can introduce
new confounding.
That is a problem, if we
don't summarize history well.
But we can also have
unobserved confounders,
just like we can in
the one-step setting.
One example is if we have
an unobserved confounded
in the same way
as we did before.
It impacts both the
action at time 1
and the reward at time 1.
But of course, now we're
in the sequential setting.
The confounding structure
could be much more complicated.
We could have a confounder
that influences an early action
and a late reward.
So it might be a
little harder for us
to characterize what is the
set of potential confounders?
So I just wanted
to point that out
and to reinforce that
this is only harder
than the one-step setting.
So we're wrapping up now.
I just want to end on
a point about the games
that we looked at before.
One of the big reasons
that these algorithms were
so successful in
playing games was
that we have full observability
in these settings.
We know everything from
the game board itself--
when it comes to Go, at least.
We can debate that when it
comes to the video games.
But in Go, we have complete
observability of the board.
Everything we need to know
for an optimal decision
is there at any time point.
Not only can we observe
it through the history,
but in the case of Go, you don't
even need to look at history.
We certainly have Markov
dynamics with respect
to the board itself.
You don't ever have to remember
what was a move earlier on,
unless you want to read into
your opponent, I suppose.
But that's a game
theoretic notion
we're not going
to get into here.
But more importantly, we
can explore the dynamics
of these systems
almost limitlessly,
just by simulation
and self-play.
And that's true regardless if
you have full observability
or not-- like in
StarCraft, you might not
have full observability.
But you can try your
things out endlessly.
And contrast that with
having, I don't know,
700 patients with rheumatoid
arthritis or something
like that.
Those are the samples you have.
You're not going
to get new ones.
So that is an amazing
obstacle for us
to overcome if we want
to do this in a good way.
The current
algorithms are really
inefficient with the
data that they use.
And that's why this limitless
exploration or simulation
has been so important
for these games.
And that's also
why the games are
the success stories of this.
A last point is that
typically for these settings
that I put here, we have
no noise, essentially.
We get perfect observations
of actions and states
and outcomes and
everything like that.
And that's really true in
any real-world application.
All right.
I'm going to wrap up.
Tomorrow-- nope,
Thursday, David is
going to talk about
more explicitly
if we want to do this properly
in health care, what's
going to happen?
We're going to have a great
discussion, I'm sure, as well.
So don't mind the slide.
It's Thursday.
All right.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]